what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime opera and today I will be
breaking down the most recent events of
the seven deadly sins story including
the incredible battle that is currently
taking place between the demon king at
his strongest level of power yet and the
sins and elizabeth i will be explaining
what exactly is happening and likely to
happen next and I will give you my
thoughts and all of it right here in
this video so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the seven deadly sins
content on this channel and you'd like
to see more please leave a like to let
me know and if you're new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell I just want to
give a real quick thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons I will talk
about them in greater detail at the end
of the video but we now have over 30
patrons thank you guys so much you make
all of this possible please be advised
that this video is looking at the latest
developments in the seven deadly sins
story so manga spoilers are coming up
proceed with caution you have been
warned Chapter three - one of the manga
was just a great chapter overall we
learned some important new information
we got lots of action and we had the
return of the one and only Lord s Kannur
also known on this channel as Big Daddy
sunshine let's get some hashtag Big
Daddy sunshine down in the comments
everybody in the previous chapter
chapter 320 we saw bond Merlyn go third
Deanne and King arriving at the magical
lake after defeating the massive
Lovecraftian in Deraa
their intention now is to work together
with meliodas and Elizabeth to defeat
the demon king the sins make it clear
that they are here to help
but meliodas is not happy he tells them
that this fight has nothing to do with
them and that they need to get out of
here right now
judging from le Otis's behavior in these
last several chapters it is clear that
he doesn't want the sins involved in
this fight because he is seriously
concerned that they might be hurt or
even killed by the demon king he doesn't
want his best friends or anyone else to
have to suffer because of him and his
father bond reminds me leotis that they
fought their way out of purgatory so
that they could all be together and live
together in peace and the other sins
confirmed that they are all here to help
they want to work as a team and they
don't want the burden of defeating
the demon king to be only a Mele Otis's
shoulders but then meliodas confirms
what we've all been suspecting since the
last chapter and something that I
discussed at length in the previous
video meliora confirms that the demon
king is now way stronger than he was
before and this is a big deal this means
that the demon king is even stronger now
than he was back when he had possessed
the body of meli otis and we all
remember how long that battle took and
how hard it was for everyone to come
together in order to defeat the demon
king back then you might be wondering
why the demon king would be stronger now
inside the body of a cell dressed and he
was inside the body of Milly auras since
we know that Mele Otis is definitely
stronger than zelgius but it looks to me
like zelgius was a more compatible
vessel for the demon king
probably because Mele Otis was putting
up a bigger fight from the inside and
resisting the demon Kings control more
effectively back when he was possessing
Mele Otis the demon Kings appearance
took on the form of an adult Mele otis
and when he was first possessing the
body of zelgius the same thing happened
the demon king looked like an adult
version of zelgius however since chapter
320 the demon king has been able to take
on a new form altogether even though he
is still inside the body of zeldron he
no longer looks like an adult version of
zelgius instead he now looks the same
way that he himself used to look when he
was younger
he transcended celtris as his vessel and
has been able to attain a completely new
level of power a level of power that he
possessed at the very prime of his life
naturally this will present a bigger
challenge for the sins than back when
the demon king had control of
melioidosis body because we now know
that his control over Mele Otis had been
incomplete and he had been unable to
unlock his full potential while using
meliodas as a vessel at this point
Merlin reminds me Liotta's that she
already tricked the gods once and that
killing a god sounds like a good follow
up act so she definitely wants to be a
part of the battle against the demon
king this is just like a one line but
it's quite interesting Merlyn is
probably saying this just to reassure
meliodas so he stops worrying about them
being there but I wonder if the fact
that Merlyn brought up the time that she
tricked the gods means that we are going
to learn more about what actually
happened between her and the demon king
and the supreme deity in the past I
would love to know more about how
exactly Merlin was able to pull off
tricking them and then also escape the
destruction of Valhalla win on scale and
of course I would like to know more
about the supreme deities involvement in
the destruction of Merlin's home city we
just know so little about the supreme
deity and I am definitely anxious to
learn more the sins and Elizabeth
continue to discuss their current
predicament meliodas doesn't want them
to get hurt but the sins want to work
together as a team because that gives
them the best possible chance of winning
meanwhile the demon king isn't messing
around
he uses his immense power and somehow
resuscitates the different components of
the Endura and sends them all flying at
the sins Merlin is able to teleport the
attack back at the demon king but the
demon king activates the ruler and so
the attack doesn't hurt him Elizabeth
tries to use her power called invigorate
in order to have the ruler backfire on
the demon king because any move that is
intended to heal or make him stronger
will hurt him since the ruler reverses
the effect of each attack but his bond
points out the demon king is able to
switch the ruler off when he needs to
and he does exactly that but that's when
the teamwork kicks in because as soon as
the demon king deactivates the ruler
Merlin hits him with an offensive attack
the demon king is not amused with this
at all and Merlin tries to take
advantage of the moment in order to get
gold her to infiltrate the demon Kings
soul and help zelgius break free from
the demon Kings control but this won't
be so easy the demon king uses his giant
sword to deal with all incoming attacks
and even though gothert rise to get my
leotis into the demon Kings soul while
the others are keeping him busy the
demon king is able to repel all the
attacks infiltrating the demon Kings
soul will not be so easy this time
around and even if they are successful
that means that the rest of the sins and
Elizabeth are going to have to hold off
the demon king and protect the bodies of
gold and melly Otis on the outside while
the two of them are looking for zelgius
on the inside
needless to say trying to resist the
current power of the demon king without
direct help from Elias seems like a
virtually impossible task at this point
and just then in that exact moment when
the sins desk
need more power in order to keep the
demon king at bay the one and only Big
Daddy sunshine enters the fray Eskin or
appears blocks the demon King's sword
with nothing but his bare hand and the
chapter ends with the words the
mightiest always arrive late and of
course the glorious moustached face of
Eskin or stares back at us from the
final page I had a feeling that now that
s Connor has sunshine once again he will
play a major role in this fight and that
is exactly how things are shaping up at
this point the demon king seems to be
too powerful for the sins to keep at bay
for long enough on the outside suddenly
Otis can look for zell just as
consciousness on the inside they will
need a miracle and a ton of teamwork to
make this happen but s kannur with
sunshine and especially a scanner in his
the one form is probably the best hope
they have you will recall the during the
previous fight against the demon king
when the demon king was possessing
meliodas Eska nor did not have sunshine
he had given sunshine over to my L so
that my L could defeat the original
demon so during that battle s Kannur was
pretty much useless and my L didn't
really do too much either if we're being
honest however we now have a situation
in which the demon king is even stronger
than he was before
but luckily s Kannur is back at full
power so this time he will be able to
play an important role
I expect that s Canora might even unlock
another level of power because of how
high the stakes are and how badly he
must have protect all of his friends but
with that said we also to remember what
Miles said to ask on or before giving
sunshine back to him
s can ORS human body is already at its
limit and exerting himself too much
using sunshine could literally kill him
s Kannur has shown multiple times that
he is willing to sacrifice his life for
his friends so it is very possible that
s Koerner may push himself too far in
this battle and put his own life in
serious danger
now that s Canora has arrived all seven
sins in Elizabeth are on the battlefield
the battle is only now getting serious
and we could expect a two-pronged battle
to ensue in the next chapter on inner
battle to save zelgius and an outer
battle against the demon king in the
physical realm what's more I suspect
that even though all the sins are now
here we still haven't seen all the
actors enter the stage I believe that at
some point in the future we are going to
see gelda
Hawk Hawks mama Arthur Pendragon and
maybe even the supreme deity make an
appearance this battle is just getting
started and I expected to take quite
some time to unfold fully whatever
happens I can't wait to keep reading and
keep enjoying the ride
teamwork is sure to play a crucial role
in this fight as we saw in this chapter
with the teamwork that Elizabeth and
Merlin demonstrated and I really can't
wait to see epic fights like this one
get animated it's going to take the
seven deadly sins anime to a completely
new level in my opinion it's going to be
glorious let me know what you guys think
what are your thoughts on the latest
chapter and how do you think the battle
will unfold do you agree with me that we
are still going to see gelda Hawk Hawks
mama and other characters appear on the
battlefield
let me know down in the comments if you
enjoyed the seven deadly sins content on
this channel and you want to see more
you can leave a like to let me know and
if you're new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications that is the only way you
will be actually notified by YouTube I
want to give a huge thank you to all of
our anime upper patrons for supporting
our work and making our work possible a
special thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King zelgius and on hell crews another
massive thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby ray ace
Ingrid ah al Olin Adam madam AK
makoto-kun and keelon and finally at the
very pinnacle of interdimensional
greatness a tier reserved only for
legends a massive thank you to Regan
Harrison and Lord Noxon or disciples of
Lord we go himself if you feel that our
content provides value for you and you
want to support more be sure to check
out our patreon link in the description
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]